penser qu'on est dur avec les choucas
qu'on travaille avec de nouveaux de même
on lui rend service
comme nous autres on vous riez on fera
quoi dans société
on est tonique thinkequity travail mais
lui et hurle dell qui est belle mais
c'est pas ça prend aux shoots et
agriculteurs ça fait 40 ans que je suis
propriétaire de la ferme à monter
[Musique]
ça toujours utile avant tout dans notre
ami au contraire c'est ça mon père avait
des chevaux je sais qu'il faut plus
jamais travailler tu es fou d'en avoir
toute une vie sébastien trop fort avec
bmc tout le conduit mais qui n'arrive à
atlas la bourse très attention à voir
jean sébastien kimongo qu'on ne l'était
surtout du bon sens et antoine ces
stagiaires d'école sérum et puis les 4 e
books automatiquement sa fine équipe
dont une année avec les chaumes et on va
partir au monde a envie launay dalbo
puis après ça il faut un bac d'un sucre
après ça ils vont fait récemment les
faux pas que les choses autoroute en
tout temps de travail à faire tout
sauter le cerveau tout perdre si tu vois
c'est lui qui ont versé au dernier bal
dans le mode mois d'octobre le cheval
ces quelques pas de n'importe où
n'importe quand ça tout briser les sols
comme suit le même chemin que chaque
attaque en voyant un peu tout et où
beaucoup de traces chacun près seule
elle est la leur pose est bien facile à
faire aux autres at one way je vois ce
truc qui ce qu'elle me voit allait
commencer à préparer n'a rien de
rechercher quand on sélectionne au
soleil pour regarder ces malades comme
siècle celui de la sève qui coule donc
lui c'est certain que si tu le récupère
pour être sa part est en train de mourir
ça que le ivoire et rick perry
[Musique]
oh
avec le cheval n'est capable d'être un
art spécifique n'est pourvu que ça
décroche même poste j'en ai fait faire
cette autant de place que nous autres on
voyait lui brisa mari il ya une petite
machine technique est sortie ça le tour
de france avec les cours de fonds saab
quand un cheval peut pas résister voie
d'eau tout autre respecter la nature
danse au moins apprécié de l'agriculture
durable que nos enfants nous tiens va
faire la même chose c'est tellement gros
même pas dans le même contexte
la production quand on est avec un
cheval de même ses moyens
stop ciel mais ça paye hamas toutes les
preuves que ça peut encourir parce que
le cheval ne nous apporte pas des
paiements de fou à faire pour bouger de
fait les autres groupes groupe groupe
bureau s'est passé on a une vie braye
qu'il soit aux causes pendantes on est
tous très bien d'elle mouche content de
son jeu j'ai pour vos autres que ce que
tu as ma vie sous cette seule et la
passion c'est là bas aux états étaient
pas obligés de 33 semaines en vacances
un mois par année pour être heureux
c'était heureux toute sa vie côté
positif c'est par sa lettre m'a fait que
trois d'être quelqu'un de dessous rien
qu'à tarifs de soins de quelques heureux
ou n'importe quoi c'est parce que ça va
être vraiment vraiment à vomir sur la
voie postale heures que cette info les
gens qui ne considèrera en arrière il ya
maintenant 30 ans aujourd'hui qui
commence à comprendre ces personnes 9 08
arriérés sub secours du disque c'est la
boîte de bon sens dans le bois ce choix
c'est l'avenir malgré tout
[Musique]